sind elektroautos ein riesiger schwindel
glaubt man einer aktuellen studie
belasten elektroautos das klima um elf
bis 28 stärker als diesel pkw der
analyse zufolge hat ein mercedes c220
mit dieselmotor in deutschland eine
bessere co2 bilanz als eines der
populärsten elektroautos überhaupt der
tesla modell 3 willkommen bei klicks und
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinieren des seins venus abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
die harte kritik an diesen berechnungen
hat nicht lange auf sich warten lassen
der vorwurf es wurde mit falschen zahlen
und annahmen gerechnet die eine
besonders ungünstige klimabilanz der
elektroautos zur folge haben es scheint
als wollten uns immer öfter lobbyisten
mit solchen fehlinformationen gezielt
manipulieren
zu welchem ergebnis kommt man wenn man
ein paar fragwürdige annahmen in den
berechnungen verändert die umstrittene
studie kommt von hans werner sinn dem
ehemaligen präsidenten des ifo instituts
für wirtschaftsforschung und christoph
buch als physikprofessor an der
universität köln der sich allerdings
bisher noch nicht mit dem thema
elektromobilität beschäftigt hatte und
ihr urteil zur ökobilanz von
elektroautos fällt alles andere als gut
aus die studie vergleicht zwei fahrzeuge
die sich nur bedingt für einen vergleich
eignen ein mercedes c220 und ein tesla
modell 3 schon hier ist anzumerken dass
der tester modell 3 mit 3 151 ps
deutlich leistungsstärker ist als die
c-klasse die in diesem fahrzeug auf 194
ps kommt doch ein leistungsstärkeres
diesel autos stößt natürlich auch mehr
gramm pro kilometer aus das heißt im
klartext dass so die bilanz für das
diesel auto gleich ein wenig schlechter
ausgefallen wäre
ein weiteres großes problem der studie
die autoren rechnen mit normverbräuche
dabei wissen wir mittlerweile dass die
real verbräuche bis zu 40 prozent über
den normverbräuche liegen und zwar bei
den verbrennungsmotoren und bei
elektromotoren und das beeinflusst die
klimabilanz enorm hinzu kommt das
testmodell 3 hat eine sehr große
batterien kapazität von 75
kilowattstunden im durchschnitt liegt
diese bei autos die 2018 in deutschland
verkauft wurden bei nur 30 kilowatt
damit ist auch schnell klar dass auch
diese gewählte variablen die klimabilanz
des elektroautos schlechter ausfallen
lässt denn je kleiner die batterie ist
umso geringer ist auch der co2 ausstoß
je kilometer
der der batterie bei der produktion zu
gerechnet wird bleiben wir direkt beim
thema denn klar ist allein die
produktion der batterie ist sehr
energieintensiv doch entscheidend ist
hier welcher strom verwendet wird die
autoren der ifo studie nehmen für ihre
berechnung an
das sehr viel kohle strom genutzt wird
das ergebnis ist bekannt eine angeblich
miese co2 bilanz des tesla noch tesla
produziert viele batterien in den usa
und nutzt dabei in erheblichem umfang
solarstrom
hier ist also entscheidend wo die
batterie produziert wird und wie hoch
der anteil von erneuerbaren energien ist
ähnlich sieht es bei der ladung des
elektroautos aus hans werner sinn und
sein kollege gehen in ihrer studie vom
aktuellen strommix in deutschland aus
und der hat mit etwa einem drittel einen
wirklich hohen anteil an kohle strom und
zwar weil die bundesregierung ihren
versprechen zum pariser klimaabkommen
nicht einhält zukünftig soll sich das
aber ändern und der gesamte strom in
deutschland soll emissionsfrei werden
dies würde einhergehen mit einer
deutlich besseren co2 bilanz der
elektroautos somit hängt die co2 bilanz
eines elektroautos also davon ab in
welchen ländern sie geladen werden in
deutschland stecken in einer
kilowattstunde derzeit 550 gramm co2 in
norwegen sind es nur 60 gramm
im umkehrschluss könnte man also
behaupten dass in ländern mit einem
hohen kohlestromanteil
verbrennungsmotoren tatsächlich sinn
machen
doch dabei bitte nicht vergessen schon
jetzt gibt es in deutschland die
möglichkeit elektroautos mit 100 prozent
ökostrom zu laden
bleiben wir bei der batterie und kommen
zum letzten kritikpunkt denn hier gehen
die autoren der ifo studie von einer
eher schlechten laufleistung von 150.000
kilometern aus beachtet wird jemand
nicht dass tesla selbst für die große
batterie eine garantie von bis zu 192
1000 kilometern verspricht und es schon
zahlreiche teslas mit laufleistung von
mehr als 400.000 kilometern gibt und
zudem eignen sich viele acuson nach der
nutzung im auto die noch für weitere
einsatzmöglichkeiten beispielsweise als
stationärer stromspeicher im haus auch
wird eine viel zu kurze lebensdauer
überhaupt vom fahrzeug
angenommen was das ergebnis zugunsten
des verbrennungsmotors verschieben und
so kommen kritiker auf ihren vorwurf
dass die studie von hans werner sinn und
seinem kollegen elektroautos bewusst
schlecht rechnet denn klar ist dass die
autoren hier vom status quo in
deutschland ausgehen außerdem
vergleichen sie mit den beiden
fahrzeugen apple mit würden zudem
rechnen sie auch mit einer relativ co2
intensiven produktion der batterien
außer acht gelassen wird dass sich das
in naher zukunft ändern wird oder eben
gar nicht der fall ist und so haben
nicht nur das umweltbundesamt und das
bundesumweltministerium den aktuellen
berechnungen widersprochen
unter den kritikern ist auch der
deutsche automobilhersteller volkswagen
das unternehmen hat eine große studie
zum co2 fußabdruck seiner modelle
gemacht und so eine art
lebenszyklusanalyse seiner autos
vorgenommen daran verteidigt volkswagen
die ökobilanz der elektroautos die
analyse der co2 emissionen aller produkt
stadien zeige die nach ganz klar dass
die e-autos in der klimabilanz den
verbrennern überlegen sind dazu merkels
gern ochs von volkswagen
der elektroantrieb hat im europäischen
durchschnitt die beste klimabilanz
vereinfacht gesagt lässt es sich
folgendermaßen zusammenfassen diesel und
benziner verursachen die meisten co2
emissionen während der nutzung der
ausstoß von treibhausgasen passiert beim
elektroauto vor allem bei der produktion
laut der analyse von volkswagen kommt
ein elektroauto während der produktion
auf 57 gramm co2 je kilometer
ein diesel liegt bei 129 gramm co2 je
kilometer
darin eingerechnet ist auch die
rohstoffgewinnung und genau hier liegen
die herausforderung in der autobranche
fast die hälfte der co2 emissionen fällt
auf die rohstoffgewinnung und die
produktion der batterie noch volkswagen
ist dran bis 2050 will der hersteller
komplette klimaneutralität erreichen
auch die lieferanten sollen auf
nachhaltigkeit verpflichtet werden wenn
in den kommenden zehn jahren 22
millionen elektroautos alleine von
volkswagen produziert werden und schon
2020 soll das erste reine elektro modell
der golf klasse auf den markt kommen und
zwar mit einer klimaneutralen ökobilanz
die wissenschafts community jedenfalls
ist sich aufgrund aussagekräftige
studien einig
unter realistischen bedingungen stoßen
elektroautos weniger co2 aus und sind
somit klimaschonender als autos mit
verbrennungsmotoren auch wenn die
emissionen während der produktion
berücksichtigt werden ganz wichtig
kritisch allerdings bleibt das thema
umweltverträglichkeit und endlichkeit
der rohstoffe vor allem lithium und
kobalt sind problematisch denn noch ist
es nicht übertrieben dass sich fast alle
studien einig sind dass elektroautos in
der nutzung enorme vorteile gegenüber
diese und auch benzin fahrzeugen haben
sie sind nicht nur beim energieverbrauch
günstiger sondern dann auch bei der
wartung und bei der reparatur und so
munkelt man mittlerweile nicht mehr mehr
mehr unter vorgehaltener hand dass diese
studie mit absicht genau zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt veröffentlicht wurde
schließlich hatte sich der chef von
volkswagen herbert diess gerade jetzt
auf elektromobilität festgelegt und auch
von der politik gesellschaft unternehmen
eine radikale wende in diesem bereich
gefordert
seiner meinung nach ist dies die light
technologie der zukunft klar ist auch
dass er damit auf widerstand trifft denn
es gibt nicht wenige firmen die von
verbrennungsmotoren sehr stark abhängig
sind und so passiert es dass eben genau
diese unternehmen studien in auftrag
geben und zwar mit einem ergebnis das
ihrem ansinnen entspricht und so ist es
für lobbyisten gar nicht so schwierig
fehlinformationen zu streuen und uns
damit zu manipulieren hans werner sinn
und sein kollege fehlen sich aber
keineswegs dazu und verteidigen ihre
studie in einer aktuellen stellungnahme
heißt es in unserer studie wollen wir
einer breiten öffentlichkeit erläutern
dass e-autos im gegensatz zur
politischen klassifizierung und
öffentlichen wahrnehmung nicht a priori
co2 emissionsfrei sind die autoren gehen
sogar noch weiter und behaupten dass man
manche ihrer annahme als viel zu günstig
im sinne des elektromotors kritisieren
könnte dazu heißt es in der
stellungnahme
wir finden es erstaunlich dass diese
aspekte von manchen kritikern nicht
gesehen werden die uns vorwerfen wir
hätten die e-autos mit extremsten 1
zugunsten des diesels schlecht gerechnet
diesen vorwurf weisen wir mit nachdruck
zurück sind spielt damit unter anderem
auf einen hohen energiebedarf für die
heizung eines elektroautos an der in der
viel kritisierten studie aber komplett
unberücksichtigt zudem betonen hans
werner sinn und
die studienautoren auch das ist bei
ihrer arbeit keineswegs um eine
auftragsstudie handelt für die sie
bezahlt wurden und alle beteiligten
autoren in keiner wirtschaftlichen
beziehung zur energie und
automobilwirtschaft stehen ich frage
mich dann nur immer welche autos diese
leute eigentlich waren es wird deutlich
wie wichtig es ist genau hinzuschauen
und das ergebnis einer studie nicht
einfach per se so hinzunehmen denn jetzt
wird noch einmal klar
die auswahl der variablen kann nicht
weniger als über das gesamtergebnis
einer studie entscheidend zudem ist es
sogar möglich dass unterschiedliche
interessenlage ein und dieselbe studie
nutzen um auf ein völlig
unterschiedliches fazit zu kommen
einfach in dem genau die teile der
untersuchung hervor gehoben werden die
dem jeweiligen interesse entsprechen
bloß nicht aufhören mit dem kritischen
hinterfragen denn nur so kann eine
ernsthafte wissenschaftliche diskussion
über dieses thema möglich werden diese
studie
so viel steht fest trägt ebenfalls nicht
zu dieser ernsthaften diskussionen bei
ich kann nur sagen wer mit der politik
in diesem und anderen bereichen
unzufrieden ist sollte erstens unbedingt
am 26 mai zur europawahl gehen
und zweitens genau die partei wählen die
die standpunkte vertritt die einem
wichtig sind wir sind diejenigen die
entscheiden also lasst es uns tun
hashtag diesmal wähle ich mehr dazu im
video von mikro dropmann kritik die eu
wichtige info anklicken und anschauen
würde ich mal sagen wir sehen uns am 26
mai im wahllokal bis dann bleibt dran